[Music]
I'm scared
not only I'm here
[Applause]
give way to Christ
my glory the lifter of my headphones
[Music]
foreign
I know it's unusual in this day and age
to devote your life to something
spiritual hey good morning Anne but ever
since my mother's issues I've always
felt a calling to help people
[Music]
Natalie's parents believe that she is
being possessed by some sort of evil
entity
which is not as scary as she looks she
can hear you
you're my favorite person here us girls
we gotta stick together in this place
we have a female student in a class only
as an observer because as you know women
are strictly forbidden from performing
exorcism female surgeons are once
Unthinkable somebody had to be the first
when you enter the room of the possessed
you are walking onto a Battlefield
extractor Lord into the Beast not
defiling this innocent child
[Music]
you have a gift I'd like to teach you
this relationship it's personal we all
have a personal relationship with God
and with God
this feeling has followed me my entire
life
you got my invitation
we've been waiting for you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]